India's Prime Minister narenda Modi has
opened a temple in the northern state of
UT Pradesh the shrine was built on the
grounds where a MOS stood for centuries
before it was destroyed by Hindu
right-wing activists Alex bed
reports a long held dream of India's
Hindu nationalists becoming a
reality a Temple dedicated to Lord Ram
one of the most revered deities in
Hinduism and with it prime minister
Narendra modes janata party the BJP
fulfills a campaign promise it made
three decades ago Modi is not going to
lose a single opportunity to try to sell
the accomplishment of having built a
temple the construction of the more than
$200 million Temple which began in 2020
has been
contentious it's built on the site of
the bub Masjid a 16th century mosque
demolished by Hindu right-wing activists
in 19
1992 that led to Nationwide communal
riots that killed at least 2,000 people
mostly Muslims and bombings in the city
of
Mumbai more than 30 years later India's
current religious fault lines still lie
here Temple politics has resonated with
India's majority Hindus who make up
nearly 80% of the country's 1.4 billion
population in 2014 they elected n ra
Modi after he promised to build a shrine
on the very spot of the site of the
demolished mosque a decade later he made
it
reality the Temple's inauguration comes
months ahead of national polls as Mii
seeks a third consecutive
ter most opposition politicians are
boycotting the ceremony they accuse
Mod's party of exploiting religion for
political
gains while the party is yet to Launch
an official election campaign modi's
supporters believe the ram Temple is a
promise
fulfilled Hindu people definitely think
that there was someone who brought up
this issue and made it and perhaps the
public should reward
Modi while some Hindus celebrate many
Muslims across the country are on a
self-imposed curfew they fear attacks
and
violence for our Hindu Brothers It's a
good day but what about us
those of us who were ruined of course
will be in pain on that day our father
was killed and our mosque was demolished
too critics say under M's leadership the
religious divide has only widened some
200 million Muslims India's largest
minority group Live in Fear as second
class
citizens Muslims have been lynched over
allegations of eating beef or smuggling
cows Muslim businesses have been been
boycotted houses bulldozed women barred
from wearing head scarfs and some
educational institutions and MKS set on
fire but Mii has maintained silence
there's a fear that this government and
all the Affiliates they want to wipe out
all traces of Muslim or Islamic
civilization from the country the
Fanfare around the temple is being seen
as a victory for the Hindu nationalist
movement and as Mii seeks a third term
it's raising concerns that he's
cementing his legacy as the leader who
can transform India's secular democracy
into a Hindu nationalist State Alex
beard Al
jazer okay let's get more on this with
Sanjay capore he joins us from New Delhi
he's editor of the hard news magazine
thank you for joining us firstly tell us
a bit more about this Temple and its
significance I've heard it being
described as the new Vatican for the
Hindus is that a fair description
uh thank you for inviting me uh aoda
means especially this mov means far more
than just elections it seem to be the
coming of age for Hindu India it is not
just Hindus in India who celebrating
this entire bjp's network the ecosystem
it operates has seen that Hindus all
over the world are actually looking at
how this entire Temple has come up in
the last 10 years as promised by Prime
Minister Modi and uh elections are
incidental because I think what Mr Modi
has been able to do is to change the
nature of India from a secular
constitutionally mandated secular India
into a Hindu India and it become a very
irreversible thing even when you have
election and for strange circumstances
the BJP loses and Congress comes to par
it'll be very difficult to change the
order of things that have been Unleashed
today I remember many years ago when the
bar Maj brought down in 1992 there was a
gentleman who the editor of a newspaper
and started crying and he said India is
not going to be the same again that time
I did not realize that what it really
meant but today I can and what does it
mean what does it mean I mean to be it's
you say that Modi has pulled India away
from its secular foundations what impact
has that had on say minority uh
communities so as uh your the your
correspondent said just a short while
back the minorities at most
uncomfortable at the idea what has
happened uh they think that the
so-called divide between the Hindus and
Muslims is going to increase the voting
the votes are going to become irrelevant
because primarily Indian secularism was
also sustained by the kind of influence
the H the Muslim votes had over the
outcome they used to uh Ally with the
other backward and other operis classes
and vote vote out whoever was in their
Reckoning but with the bjp's entire
policy of putting all the Hindus in
bracket you must remember Hindus about
85% of the population so there is
nothing that the Muslims with a very
small percentage of vs can really do and
or change the order of things in the in
the in the society is basically uh a
very Hindu Constitution it's a very
Hindu society which is going to emerge
out of it not the Constitution
Constitution remains unchanged I said
that wrongly uh this Hindu Society will
probably dominate the politics and every
other thing what is also done to other
political parties become a touchstone
for deciding how they should conduct
themselves and they are not in a
position to oppose very much and they
may not like to attend the program today
but they have said it so many times that
Lord Ram is close to their heart and
they will come whenever they feel like
it to the temple because the religion
doesn't invol inviting people over to
come and come for the
ceremony you were referring there to the
opposition parties who I believe are
staying away from the opening of this
Temple can you explain in a little more
detail why that
is primarily because I think they
recognize that this is not just a
Hindu religion event but it's basically
the bjp's party event because you have
the Prime Minister who is not supposed
to be involved in consecration it has to
be done by the Brahman the the Priestly
class and you have if you look at the uh
the list of people who are there doing
during the ceremony is the BJP chief
minister from up you have the RSS Chief
the the parental party organization of
the BJP the totally right-wing entity
and you have many others who all belong
to the so-called Hindu hind parar that's
a family of the hinda and uh they don't
want to give legitimacy to this and at
the same time the BJP wants that if they
come and uh present themselves they
would be endorsing not the BJP but the
Hindu uh rise at the moment which has
happened especially with the coming of
age of the warrior king Lord Ram so
there is a visible conflict which is
available which is visible at the moment
okay uh with the opposition parties not
really Keen to give legitimacy to
whatever is happening now they may
believe in Lord dram but they don't want
to hear okay I understand okay thank you
so much for your analysis Sanjay Koopa
kapor speaking to us there from New
Delhi thank you so much